Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
(Música)
Nunca vi una cosa así,
una idea tan simple muy bien explicada.
Cambiar, algo hay que cambiar,
o no va a quedar nada,
todo va a seguir igual;
y vos no querés que siga igual, o sí.
Hablar, probemos con hablar,
Te digo lo mío, pero te escucho hablar.
Escuchar hablar, escuchar hablar.
Escuchar hablar, escuchar.
No de forma tribal.
La cosa está complicada.
Tenés la respuesta y no podés usarla.
Mirar el dolor de los otros
te ayuda a ver en perspectiva el propio.
El derecho en forma enmarañada,
defender lo que sos,
que no decidan por vos.
Hay que moverse, usar la palabra.
Participación, acción, reacción.
Harry Potter me enseñó a luchar,
tengo un cutter y lo voy a usar.
Para cortar un poco de tela,
armar la bandera, hacerlo en conjunto.
El idealismo está
en lo profundo de los genes.
Para curar no siempre hay que operar.
Esa idea re puede dar para documentar.
Hey, lo podemos filmar,
de que tenga entrevistas
yo me puedo encargar.
Lo podemos hacer en el domo si lo prestan.
Por suerte contamos con los que nos siguen
que van a desobedecer con furia y amor.
Los dibujos animados, imágenes ilimitadas,
pero siempre falta una.
Y los pobres juntándola en pala.
El interés no está solo en los bancos,
ni en las islas de los millonarios,
ni en sus milicias.
No perdamos tiempo de caricia.
Es que hay tan poco tiempo
y todo se está incendiando
a costa de las mujeres
y eso hay que cambiarlo ya.
(Aplausos) Seguir aprendiendo
en un lugar nuevo
y hacerlo junto a alguien
que se parece a vos.
Por suerte contamos con los que nos siguen
que van a desobedecer con furia y amor.
Y quiero estudiar los psicodélicos
y entenderlos.
Quiero ver si pueden
tirarle una onda a la salud.
Y quiero que estaciones tu satélite
en mi asteroide
(Risas)
Y quiero estar seguro
de que vos también querés.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.